huge storm it has gone off war rebellion
and revolution for more than a decade
I've been outside Britain reporting on
some of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and I want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
twelve years
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a tiny island and it's
absolutely full up at the moment
richard is a man on a mission
I'm positive about the brexit that you
know they might stop millions of people
coming here he has all the symbols of
success but doesn't like the way his
country's going
it doesn't feel Great Britain anymore
you know you feel that you've got to
watch what you say
you can't upset people you know you feel
that you're yielding to other cultures I
wanted to find out from Richard why
during my time away so many people now
share his view and have hardened their
stand against migrants and asylum
seekers well they they've come across 20
other countries where they've been safe
to come here he eats the benefits if you
put the lid on the jam pop the wasps
won't come
you know that that would be really
offensive to a lot of people well it's
just it's just a little british analogy
you know there we go again you know
that's as things that we we sort of
sight you know
Richard owns hotels in Essex a Southend
boy made good who's moved his home and
part of his business to the countryside
what it means to me is space it's not
being too overcrowded having nice
neighbors you know my neighbors are
lovely here is this the green and
pleasant land that you have in your mind
absolutely yeah absolutely
and Richards friends seem to feel
equally patriotic and defensive this is
Great Britain apart of Great Britain
it's nice to have that opened it sees
normally the far left that ridicule the
flag anyone who shows any patriotism
that they don't like it you know so
you're a racist because you know you fly
a flag or you've got Union Jack this or
Union Jack that we voted to come out of
a corrupt organization configure
European Union that's what I voted for
it's done a lot of things one thing it
has done it it's make people less
accepting the foreigners simply because
there's so many and that's a natural
thing you know I feel at a house and you
invited a lodger in and then they
brought ten other people with them that
you didn't expect to arrive you get the
uncle you wouldn't be too pleased about
it and that's what's hoping with Britain
I spin I spend a lot of time that side
not this side Richards customers - even
those who've emigrated notice a change
but your personal experience has been
it's been really lovely coming to
England because the visitors accepted us
like one of their own but now
everybody's coming into the country like
foreigners and they not really being
accepted you know so you find that
strange or sad or I think there's too
many coming into the country yeah it is
yeah I'm gonna follow you Richard
were you ready now yeah
and your aim basically to try and give
people a very English British experience
yes oh yes oh yes tell me I think me
behind that everyone loves a full
English breakfast bacon sausage beans
mushrooms tomatoes toasty you can't beat
it how this and breakfast it affected
your whole business it's made it much
better for people come to this country
and have cheaper holidays and it's just
way too simple from going abroad rather
a short break in the UK and then an
expensive holiday abroad the only thing
we can't guarantee is the sunshine but
once we've got the sunshine you can't be
Great Britain I am a little bit worried
but the way is going but English people
seem to move out of the inner cities so
where it becomes not English
people are moving out so for instance
Essex is a white flight area so all the
people from London you know the
indigenous people are moving out so
these places are becoming like ghettos
that are not British and places but here
are our British so I'm quite happy to
live here this is the image that most
people associate Authority that's a long
snaking line of people having been on
the ground with the hundreds of
thousands involved in the mass migration
I wanted to know how Richard viewed
these same images unconcerned for the
English people first you know we get a
raw deal I don't think we should be
looking to the rest look after the rest
of the planet when we've got our own
problems you know Jessica is changing
the makeup of British society what we're
seeing he's a huge
influx of millions of people no you know
effectively illegal immigrants is
someone who breaks into your country no
if someone broke into your house there'd
be called a burglar and arrested but if
you break into a country you get
benefits
it seems perception often holds more
sway than statistics and Richards fight
to keep his vision of Britain isn't
stopping anytime soon